you
just in time I am hopping into a
tournament the eastern bold arena the
mic is in place here all right one hour
of bullet chess
should be able to track the tournament
town you know I was thinking when I was
just quickly on break there now that
puzzle we did it should have been taken
out there like another mover to to the
point where you have to actually take
the night with the pawn oh well here we
are now playing bullet chess a good
change from staring at that puzzle oof
all right this is a giant clown here on
c6 it's good I'd like to exchange this
pond let's break this down let's not
think too much I'm working with the
hanging pawn structure have a couple
pounds okay I got a makuu
it's not expecting that I just dropped
the rook and I am officially losing Rick
there's good okay this one this one
isn't gonna go well there's being sneaky
just then all right I have nothing
maybe I scooped up the night oughta hope
Jess I am in some big trouble
I guess I have to try getting here well
we're pretty slow now eight seconds and
I made it natural
oh my god
why I 100 man
ugly man what an ugly start oh man it's
been a while let me tell you how long a
while shake off the rust and fast cannot
have multiple games like that that's for
sure
ooh brutal down a rook and read down
upon maybe I get b7 take care take on c7
ok step up challenging my knight okay I
guess we're gonna go here and then here
gotta get out of that pan up that Bishop
is a monster let's go - I'm gonna shoot
for c5 light-square hmm I'm pretty
aggressive here on the Kings side maybe
we get some exchanges Bishop d4 let's
take once if the Queen's off I just I
want the Queen's off okay I know I'm
waiting I'm getting upon this is this is
good yeah I'll still go for this their
King might be in some trouble might
gonna stack the rooks
it's insert a Czech way down on time
maybe I should have tried a rook lift oh
that's a big slip I guess they were
trying for I'm not sure what they were
trying for there with clean F 400 they
thought it was gonna take with the Queen
that's what that was yeah
- very undeserved wins I was really
backwards on the clock with that one
that 97 f5 hmm definitely need to find a
different setup as as white in that one
flowmaster frequent opponent tough
customer
I like these structures do I get a six
let's go with the night first this
bishop should be a giant pest hang on I
get a fork I want the Queen's out clean
before my bishop is playing and there's
their Bishop is in play mm-hmm can we
double up yeah I wonder I want to get
over here I guess they're gonna get
active with that yeah and another file
opened up so why am i allowing that I
don't know why I allowed that rook to
get so active their Bishop is really
strong
need to try and get rid of that bishop
it's too strong Kings getting just
dropped upon he hikes
ah well I got made it oh why did I allow
D 5 D four I had such control over that
position Queen what was wrong with that
one
Queenie five I shouldn't have allowed
the the D for move I had really good
control over the C file okay I'm lucky
that it's only one last out of three
instead of three out of three oh I
really like my bishop on a six
okay
Carol come you gotta play a different
system all right listen let's not move
that bishop so soon um what to note here
you gotta get my bishop playing I'm
still thinking about that previous game
it must be said still on my mind for
good chess I just thought I was ready to
Castle there back to basics they may get
their Queen fish mango is the opponent
[Laughter]
why am I not getting canceled maybe it's
because it's the Queen okay let's maybe
pin the pawn one day there's ready to do
that let's step up
stop lady four okay they're going on
castled rooks unprotected
it's weird approach but uh give it a go
let's try the app no 94 can't allow that
shoo the night away
yeah move my rook is hanging over here
can't really get at him though Kenya
okay you could try that out no idea how
to assess this take a queen next time
this is there gonna be a rough
tournament no an hour of this whoo let's
keep pushing pawns I could take that
check is that me that's wait upon stab
pawn takes G to mate halt man ugliness
okay we got a lot of time left
whoo all right I'm still struggling for
a 4-2 to 0-2
all right let's try efore Cairo mmm
let's go with this doing it an early c3
because I want to tuck my bishop right
there now how annoying is this pin gonna
be let's see
struggling to move you know gonna hit me
just want to get out of that pen okay
sort of happy Yeahs I feel the struggle
the slipper oniy get the bishop I like
my I like my uh I like my knight on c4
send tricky stuff up there well aware of
it rook takes here fun I'm gonna pin out
of how are you getting out of that pin
oh you're okay with this structure I
guess huh let's hit this point
Oh
be queen takes rook threat soon rook on
G file Queen takes rook was a threat
I want to flush that Queen away it's
just way Queens way too good no no not
that either struggling to try and stay
coordinated I'm down on the clock my
hair you got to go faster I wanna keep
some material on there going trade mode
and I put me in some pin stick around
over here Queen f6 Queen f6 check and
then here mate threats out the Queen
five more do have more I got the rook
all right can I pre move out yes but to
get this one all right back to termer we
got another to run fire maybe the first
four is right around the corner you just
finished he's gonna smack me around
again no Hall my first opponent the one
where I was a lucky duck wow this is
different okay this bishop is a killer
isn't it love that bishop Wow
different kind of play it's queen kind
of what is she doing weird moves man Wow
taking with the pawn that's surprising
can't survive that can you I'm dropping
stuff let's go back okay we're gonna go
here we're gonna get out of a diagonal
check this ready to drop stuff my rook
wants to be here this is so awkward this
kind of play what is happening here yeah
I guess we're gonna go here let's move
this Knight
yeah this is a wonderful structure
my night is really good they're not here
come on night you know you have a you
could do a lot better man a lot better
holy cow this is disgusting
don't meet me I have no idea how to
describe that that was the most Awkward
play I've seen I don't know what White
was doing but I had some my night went
from being a really nice piece to one
move it was a terrible piece a fiend cut
out night never a good sign why would I
even move my mouse in the direction of
that fiend cut out square it's better
way to what's happening here now I can't
describe my opponents play no okay let's
watch oversensitive square it's the only
uh I don't know that's all I could
comment just watch over a sensitive
square the queens are off I'm up a piece
my pony is a pawn for it I'll probably
get trapped if I do that let's go here
I'm gonna give him up I wanted some
trades no I like this square I like
giving up this pawn though hmm okay I'm
getting a piece you need to move the
bishop back I'll back rank mates let's
just defend my Knights gonna go hunting
boom boom boom three in a row and some
passers almost passed
oh he's hungry he's very hungry run run
run
alright now make it go a little faster
now stalemates kind of close
now here alright step ladder alright we
got this one how are we doing on the
stream the stream is still I should
probably peek from time to time it is up
and running
yes we're still here for hours in this
stream and a close battle up top here
wild breath next opponent top is at 20
I'm at 16 I have fire
let's try e3 okay a capture before my
bishop moved build my center
give me the bishop pair not so fast
won't remind a dark square bishop
exchange let's try for that yeah I don't
know seems active might go with doubled
pawns maybe six try and make something
happen on c5 try hey five must be good
oh okay I'm I still want to what do I
want to do reposition this Knight he
said he's the dummy this Knight wants to
be on c5 trying to play against this
bishop somehow flight Square stop Bishop
g4 take with this and straighten them
out a little bit more I want my knight
on a 5 how do we get him there like this
yeah now the rooks will have to watch
over this so now I want to peel open the
other side of the board here we go tough
to do this though I think I might need
my G pawn to play yeah gotta do like
this might be mo
I gotta open up something over on the G
and H files it's opening up maybe Brooke
g1 was better defend this laterally it's
gonna open up threatening upon now maybe
we open up like this one rook off okay
now I'm crashing through that pawn in
the end Falls no mates oh it's no made
snow mates and they resigned okay that
one got very strategic time takes a lot
of time to convert those I'm getting
berserk first time playing this opponent
volunteers all right hmm it seems like
it's a sneaky bullet trick type move
yeah I'll see if I'm free moving just no
no no ooh it's a fork let's open it up
get open offer exchanges don't get made
it here gopher mates
gopher mates create that account golfer
mates the animal gopher gopher mates
okay
shop here Queen takes I take the knight
let me go here we go for mates okay this
guy is in nearly all upper zerk mode 82%
jammed man irony what do we throw at the
Jama man
I guess an Enzo about a BOGO Pat is
still here I'm trying to do some similar
structure here get a fork
get that in there I see six hits with
tempo whoo
this is nice I'll go for the bishop it's
open up the C file that's the opposite
size castling so I should I should have
captured you know I got a challenge I
always have to watch out for this the
Queen doing something Queen here Queen
on B six stops Knight a5 strikes at f2
let's do that right now white square
night here Bishop b4 just kind of
waiting I'm waiting for Bishop c4 let's
not wait let's push I'll give that night
a shove Queen has a good square some
night when is it gettin turn into a
productive piece any time let's go here
is that a move okay this I think I want
okay it's opening up a little bit my
knight on c5 why didn't I think about
that sooner just want to hold my ground
a little bit I need some defense over
here okay I keep it closed I am wearing
my head on the clock okay
Oh
time burners holy cow howay too close
man way too close whoo I'm out of
playing I'm out of bullets stream
shape-shift
12:26 let's try some old Indian some old
Indian action can we build a center we
could we could do that okay
let's not stop upon you're on a roll and
you're gone oh you you acted too fast
upon too excited just a little too
excited maybe we we do something in c4
all right they got they got some weak
squares they on the rook be very careful
whoa you're trying to make me is that
even me Knight takes I have Bishop here
Queen takes I think I could survive hey
hope I could survive Knight takes here
Queen takes and then back up I have
Bishop e6 or rook here preparing to give
the rook back by getting mated and
they're just waiting to meet me no my
getting mated any Queen move threatens a
deadly night they move here but that's a
full rook I captured their um
I need to connect stuff is that working
my bishop we go here okay I'm happy yeah
I want to be able to take like this 11
seconds I get he made it I don't see it
Oh fancy I wasn't threatening anything
though no no no I'm the knight I'm on
the rook I'm on the rook they resigned
okay I was coming out on top material
material plus okay there are 168 in here
33 minutes to go
time is flying by usually does for these
bullet tournaments we got the jammed
man again let's try to eliminate their
master defender fast okay we got that am
I satisfied let's go here they're gonna
gonna try and get the light-square
bishop off let's try for some space oh
that's crumbling if I took those Knight
takes here this is collapsing
they had better there can i salvage this
miracle if that happens maybe not I
might have something in a queen side I
think I can rely upon this side of the
board I have I have some I have a
serious grip I think over there oh
that's such a good move
hitting a 400k takes I have clean here
mmm-hmm Bishop is an absolute monster oh
and a blunder it's a pin night a pins
fun Treena
Wow lucky huh let's just hammer away at
this point I was how are we surviving
this with g7 incoming pretty much no
matter what may threat on each seven got
it oh my god i blundered when that night
moved I forgot my bishop on h3 was under
fire you felt the pain it's taken right
out
mmm okay fly master Florida master seven
okay you're mixing it up a little bit
just to hear you oh I had castle let's
let's try something different okay
you're gonna go Kings side no clean side
let's let's see you're gonna get a clean
exchange we'd love to be able to take
towards the center okay I love this
position I love it so much take towards
the center now I'm done with that expand
back here come here
okay can we do something exciting
don't drop the rook keep control over
this file why am I going into the night
check let's go over here I need to play
with B for this side of the board
hmm was a scary movie
sorry about the sniffles King on B 3 I
think he likes that square
okay we're breaking it down a little bit
the knight is a little stranded hang on
let's go here I want to keep the C file
why am I going there let's hit this pawn
I'm losing the thread
and sneaky
wholesome sneaky bullet tricks in the
end there some sneaky time burners oh
that's a tough player to crack they had
a solid structure I think that's a
position you could slowly make progress
on but it takes time I don't know if I
have the time okay I like seeing c6 when
this bishop is here
okay well let's play with the C pawn
you're gonna they're gonna take yeah
we've actually been here before let's
put this bishop immediately under fire
them oh yeah you got that fancy move
here there's Knight c3 let's go here
mm-hmm
I don't know if this is good really
going pawn hunting now yes let's go here
scary the bishop is under fire
potentially keep pressure on something
okay I think my I want to move this I
wanted him of that pawn um okay I think
I just have to give that pawn up way
down on time so well
yeah stopping everything knight on f4
guard my second rank 15 seconds
converging here
oh it's too easy to play for black
that's helpful
never winning this one maybe I could get
rid of on the pawns that night is so
tricky
oh I maybe am winning that one was way
too down on the clock zero faith in
myself to pull that one off but I
somehow pulled that one off Wow
and with that that puts me up in first
with fire and we have a beefy one here I
was ready to just blunder my queen
please don't blunder you're clean so
fast yeah okay I don't have time to get
in a six so I have to just back up be
satisfied with that yeah that's so
that's a pond really going hunting okay
we have at least some imbalance here can
I make my dark square Bishop do
something we're gonna try where is their
King gonna go still an interesting
position even though I'm down upon yeah
solid they're doing their I'm gonna try
to put some some heat on the g6 pawn see
if we could manage that I try mm I have
to defend a little bit I think that's
that's clearly a time-waster time waster
oh no that's interesting know if I even
want that
maybe I do how to defend that square
that's what they had lined up they're
being sneaky and get away with this
sure I want that pond clean here on the
rook check you take my Rick I take yours
oh yeah oh good time burners man oh man
good time burners oh I was fumbling so
much come on Mouse get into better shape
I was trying to I was ready for time
burners myself and they kicked it into a
higher time burner mode ah okay 46:44 to
back with 24 to go no fires in the top
form
oh what a wild what a wild ride these
tournaments are Oh
sniping really isn't this guy gonna be a
monster let's make sure his eyes are
opened here we go this is gonna be a
beautiful Bishop and I just want to
eliminate some of the Knights look at
development in it how about this my king
where do I want my king I don't know uh
maybe over here
hang on h7 ever this time taking that
definitely this Bishop is gonna be a
beef beefy beef my bishops gonna be a
beef not a beast a beef where's the beef
where's the bishop ok Queen wants to be
pac-man what is she not eating I guess
that guy 10 seconds my knight wants to
play too
it's a it's an opposite color bishop
position if my LightSquared bishop can
get functioning in on an attack then
probably gonna be a problem
48 with fire is in first two back going
fishing it's been a while haven't forgot
about this
oh okay I'm a sweet Center let's use it
sack no sack to ask him a question rule
not castled over here I don't know if
you want to capture here let's get out
of that okay no this is a really good
piece
both my bishops forget I I love them I
really don't want to do that oh I really
don't want to do that I'm not gonna do
it then I'm gonna play pawn down if they
want to go for in for this I want some
activity maybe I could manage losing
another poem
let's take care first see pawn is not
healthy down on the clock oh did they
Mouse lip
why has my rooks my pieces are sticking
to my mouse something something weird is
happening that night could be a monster
that night is a monster need to guard my
second rank oh no I should have stopped
that no don't do that move it's too good
roof mating Nets around every corner if
that pawn got in there wait are they
getting out of the pin okay here's Mike
how fast can my king run I'll fast can
you run King careful careful
of course there's that of course there's
that
Oh what I to do is take the Queen I
didn't get that move in I'm down ah man
okay get back on the horse twenty
minutes to go where am I oh I'm six back
okay let's build a center space gonna
get some faster pre moves in there there
we go
how'd it go quicker keep the Queen's on
oh really you did that move I guess so
I want to be able to capture and open it
up okay let's not get hurt with f3
please it's just
Oh might resign quick resigner
they're playing on upper rook this guy's
playing pretty fast now this is
ridiculous okay yeah I should be okay
should be able to get this one them
right to me okay we were there um yeah I
wanted to take on Poisson if they were
gonna play that uh that e5 move I wasn't
expecting that
fifty seven fifty two forty eight I need
to get this game and then get back on
fire this is a tough opponent wouldn't
mind getting that same position again
though all right no no no this was the
one where I said I have no chance to win
and then I won so this is the last game
we played did not go over well let's
stop b5 not gonna get here let's see how
you see how he pulls that off if that
happens okay now that's sensitive you
know not sure what the point of b3 is
yeah okay so I need to regroup I'm not
sure exactly how to do this
maybe we try for me we try for beef or
try for b6
yeah or nay on b6 and nay these two
squares I have in mind
it's a pawn grab try and hold down the
light squares
I want to sacrifice this move
let's take I'm gonna that Bishop is way
too strong
feel my queen active my night mmm keep
pressure on something the King needs to
play um yeah I should hang on to that
haw boy they go into a giant prevent in
here I got nothing
no no draw
yikes okay another opponent I'm getting
berserk
okay let's try berserk back rarely do
this rarely hey let's take no I don't
want to do something else no I didn't
want to do that could have captured
their the Queen lying really fast Wow
rook
holy cow
player is so fast
Wow stalemates whoa that player was
flying
all right the the the berserk back
clearly didn't work there holy cow
okay another another tough dog here
don't want a castle too soon maybe I get
the H file on d6 straighten up my
structure let's get the get this pond
working ah man I am still surprised by
how fast that player was going Wow okay
I want I want to get this pawn if
possible I want that pond I want to save
my be pond though for sure I think I'm
getting this pawn there risky to do that
yeah no I'm just dropping that straight
away I could have captured it yeah I'm
gonna get a hit with the fork
that night needs to go it's too strong -
good night
all right he's sealed off at least I
thought he was he's gone need one rock
off think I am getting out now tuck my
king in okay straighten out my pawns
force them to take my clean scare the
scare the King away mate threat
take their
a draw oh yeah that was the guy that out
time burned me last time I realized that
the towards the end there that I had to
kick it into a higher gear repetition a
position on that one who it's been a
it's been a rough patch they're zeros
two zero one zero two zero two one zero
one far from a four okay money for
challenge this let's point some pieces
at my opponents King maybe we get the G
file to play with I take with the pawn
okay let's let's let's grab upon here I
don't want to take with the Queen I want
to take with the night okay something
something good should be happening here
I should have supported my knight it
says not how I should be doing things a
G file to open up the knight of the
knight is pinned they might move the
knight now
okay my bishop should be a good enough
defender
it's that move about mates right here I
thought I'd needed to move the knight in
order to generate main threat not the
case on the rook for mate here my knight
covers this square bishop here I could
give a check check check
checkmate assume have the files opened
there isn't a good queen check there's
no Knight check under 7-under for we're
gonna get a move I think this is the way
forward now they're just down on time I
think that was the correct way to follow
it up from there not sure under 1052 who
be lucky to get second this guy's flying
try another Sicilian okay let's play in
the center I don't know five nice
control over d4 secure night I just want
the bishop here got that jump in keep
this piece here very good okay I don't
want the night arriving here and I want
to stop f5 Wow thought I was stopping at
five okay and it's still going to do
that
okay interesting I think I'm better here
because I will have a very strong King
position in the rook now has to defend
here but that doesn't happen
very interesting idea there I'm wasting
a lot of time here
think that's the best move I want to
have this as my king's home Wow okay try
and hunt down upon okay actually I
wasn't even up close to hunting that
pond down I could have just captured
that pond what am i doing
floundering am i king over here okay
this is a one King and pawn in game
watch out for a sneaky pawn move seven
seconds is plenty now there's no sneaky
pawn Rhodes can pre move
seven minutes to go got fire 74 with
fire first Kovalchuk ova 74 with fire
that's very good I think he just
finished we might get another pairing
we'll see no this guy this is the guy
that blazed me in that uh pepper zerk
game it's too dangerous
you berserks I'm not I'm not preserving
back oh he's not here left the game oh
he's here now he's not here he's here
keeps going out what are you doing what
is up man okay Bishop d7 is kind of
weird oh love that need I need I need
that piece no no it's not let's not give
up important pawns so let's trade okay
just wanna get here weird man get that
okay geez okay let's cut out the King
for one get some ponds yeah
how is this guy so fast holy cow 31
seconds holy cow
and that's what's being down a piece
whoo okay that is I don't know I haven't
felt that before on a player that's
weird
they're ready to hunt down the pawn
again I know I know what you're up to
should probably get rid of this Bishop
while I have a chance
okay I'm playing this position no longer
down upon what do I mean no longer down
upon I was down upon in our in our first
encounter my King has actually a very
cozy shelter how do you get at Mike King
there's actually no great entry points I
don't think actually this Queen probably
pretty good there
yeah one Rockoff rook back here is
probably good thanks
Queen takes pawn as a threat
I'd have to go for a perpetual clean is
strong
things are coming off I get a pond and I
have time to take that pond wow they're
really going for it
yes I got him back I timed burned my way
to a win
oh wow they really went for it there
okay this one's gonna be the last game
oh you go all right let's take a night
who cares about the bishops it's the
last game go here give me a pawn bad
arrows watch out oh this game I tell you
you can't take upon wits check to get my
bishop um okay I was ready to go here
now that wouldn't have been a good idea
okay I'm happy over here my Knights
happy my Kings happy mm-hmm out here
there's no mate let's get a check boom I
wasn't expecting that move chase the
Queen away from defending
um I hit upon
I want my rook active that's the plan
rook c8 oh they didn't defend that pond
getting me getting me back to tournament
and that's gonna do it
pairings are closed and I will be
holding on to fourth eighty it's a
strong number eighty seventy three sixty
eight sixty is where I stand
two hundred and forty-two and all it's
been a while for a streamed build arena
but it was fun as usual okay to the two
hundred and forty two of you maybe aims
all no confetti for me
you